[Music]
hi everyone it's charlie game of thrones
had their season 8 premiere in new york
city yesterday there were a bunch of
early reviews and reactions that came
out of it we even got like a small
snippet of the brand new redesigned
opening credits sequence and they gave
it a major upgrade so i'm just gonna
break down all these early reactions and
reviews and things that the actors said
confirming a couple big theories but
remember this is just for episode one
and i'll try to keep this as
non-spoilery as possible but we're one
week away from the premiere so be sure
to subscribe
if you're new to the channel i'll be
doing videos for all the episodes all
season long
and for the game of thrones prequel tv
series which is supposed to premiere
next year
we'll also do weekly hbo now
subscription giveaways all you have to
do to enter that is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video
so we'll say thank you very much
melisandre for giving us the clips of
the new intro but we'll start with
number 10 and work our way down the list
so while this is coming from season 8
episode 1 that aired last night
so number 10 there was a message that
maisie williams and sophie turner
recorded as their characters
arya and sansa that played before the
episode warning about screenings
sansa said no photos no videos no
posting spoilers on social media then
arya said do you think that you're safe
when you get home you stupid man
you're never safe sansa said if your
phone should happen to ring during the
show your face would look lovely
on my sister's wall we will take these
matters seriously
you should as well arya replies remember
what happened to the last bastard who
effed us
and salsa says okay enjoy the show so
obviously they're referring to ramsay
bolton the last bastard who literally
effed sansa so hopefully they'll release
that clip online but it's just a really
funny thing they played to prevent
people in that crowd from releasing
spoilers
no hate on her but apparently it wasn't
quite enough of a message for melisandre
to turn her phone off and not record
that new intro sequence
but nine everybody was going crazy about
all the reunions they did say there's
epic sequences
not just table setting for the rest of
the season major
big reveals happen in very satisfying
ways and big payoffs i think the
reunions that they're speaking of
obviously are jon snow with the other
stark children
particularly john and arya reunion jon
snow in ghosts reunion because ghost is
supposed to be there during season eight
john and samwell's reunion then arya and
gendry's reunion
jorah mormont's reunion with a little
bear who's his niece you can see her
sitting right here
jaime in bran possible reunion jamie in
tyrion
possible reunion and then obviously
tyrion and sansa reunion
hello former wife are we technically
still married if you subsequently got
married to ramsay bolton
technically i do not think that they're
married because one they didn't
consummate the marriage
and two if they were still married and
the boltons tried to marry ramsay to
sansa then the rest of the north in the
realm wouldn't recognize that marriage
and that was the whole point is they
wanted legitimacy by having a stark in
winterfell and they were using sansa to
do that
so even though sansa seems like she's
gonna hate the crap out of daenerys in
the first episode
at least she'll probably enjoy tyrion's
company a little bit number eight when
they reference it not just being all
table setting for later episodes in the
big battle
is probably a reference to them paying
off jon snow learning the truth about
his parents during the episode at some
point
in daenerys learning the viserion was
raised as a white by the night king
either branstar could have told him that
or they could have gotten a raven from
the wall if the wildlings were able to
send one out in time
but the table setting stuff would mostly
just be white walkers and the night king
destroying the last hearth the car hold
on their way down to winterfell like
yeah we know they're coming
we know they're gonna crush anything in
their path and add it to the army of the
dead but just think about daenerys
getting
all that bad news the first couple of
episodes like john learning about his
parents is actually kind of good
news even though it's so monumental and
heavy it'll weigh on him he finally
learns what he's been wanting to know
his entire life
where is my mother is she still alive
does she know about me did she care
about me
daenerys is going to have to learn that
her new boyfriend is also related to her
and has a stronger claim on the iron
throne than she does
and if that wasn't enough she's going to
learn that she'll eventually have to
kill
her child the syrian again because she
thinks of the dragons as her children
is one thing to watch your child die
like she did during season seven episode
six that was heartbreaking
but then to watch it come back and have
to kill it all over again
is gonna crush her it's almost like the
first half of the season is a contest
between the writers to see how much crap
they can put daenerys through seven they
describe the violence in the episode
this is just episode one as being very
dark
brutal and unsettling and i think that's
mostly a reference to just the white
walkers and the night king making their
way south maybe destroying the last
hearth and the car hold
just completely washing over it like a
wave of undead whites
but even though it's supposed to be
super intense they do say that it's one
of the funniest episodes of game of
thrones in the history of the show
there's a whole bunch of really witty
one-liners peppered throughout from
different characters i'm assuming from
the characters that typically
get witty one-liners so you're talking
about bran varus
arya cersei tyrion maybe jamie maybe
samwell
not people like jon snow who does have
really memorable lines but he's not a
character that tells a lot of jokes
six this is actually kind of funny they
said that daenerys will have to deal
with jon's
snide sniffy sisters i guess that means
that arya also won't treat her very
nicely we knew that sansa isn't going to
like daenerys in the first episode but
apparently arya is going to be pretty
cold to her as well but they say that
that doesn't stop
her and john from showing affection with
each other in public so you know what
that means they're gonna make everyone
really uncomfortable with their pdas and
it'll be even
funnier in a bad way when they find out
that they're related
five there was another subsequent quote
that all but confirmed jon's gonna learn
the truth about rhaegar and leona stark
before the end of the first episode i
think we all expected it would happen
within the first couple of episodes
now it definitely sounds like it's
happening sometime during the first
episode
four everyone that saw the episode was
laying dramatically increased odds on
tyrion dying before the end of the
season
based on his scenes in season eight
episode one so whatever it is that he
does during the episode
makes it seem like he just jumped up the
death predictions list there's a bunch
of full frontal nudity in the episode
they didn't say who but of all the big
main characters who could possibly get
sex scenes in the episode there's jon
snow and daenerys
and maybe cersei down in king's landing
but even though gendry and arya are back
together in the same place
in joe dempsey's interview he just said
that he and arya spend their early time
back together just catching up on
everything that's happened to them
since melisandre took him mid season
three and she got picked up by the hound
so number three gendry said that he will
make himself a special new weapon during
the season
probably something with dragonglass in
the design it seems like everyone that's
standing on the line here the stark
soldiers the knights of the vale brienne
podrick the unsully the dothraki jorah
mormont brienne you know people with
valyrian swords or they've got some sort
of dragonglass variant weapon
gendry joe dempsey said that he has a
fairly active and predictable role in
the first couple of episodes preparing
for the army of the dead
so obviously you've seen him in the
trailer he's helping forge new weapons
so as you would expect he's gonna help
make all their dragonglass weapons
and he really did reiterate that he had
a lot of fun acting with maisie williams
again because it's been a couple years
since they've been together and they
both kind of matured as actors
particularly maisie williams who was
still a really little kid the last time
they had scenes together
so number two jerome flynn did an
interview talking about why he thinks
that everyone is going to hate
brawn a little more now confirming a
couple theories about what's going on
with his character at the beginning of
the season i've got a lot of big
questions about what's going on with
braun at the beginning of the season
because we haven't seen him in any of
the trailers as far as we know
so this is the actor jerome flynn's
quote about braun at the beginning of
the season he says i don't know
they might not love him as much as they
do right now talking about before the
season starts because braun is a fan
favorite character
he goes on to say but i hope they still
like him he says he is who he is talking
about his own character brawn he'll do
what he needs to get his
castle he also says that his scenes that
he filmed weren't that stressful or
strenuous
so he says he wasn't really freaked out
it wasn't like the people up in the
north filming that battle of helm's deep
episode three huge battle with the white
walkers
so a couple of things that you can glean
from that i think one when he says that
he thinks that people might not like
brawn as much as they used to
is because he will be with cersei in
king's landing
picking her side because he feels like
she's still going to give him the castle
that he's owed
it just seems like right now cersei is
the one who's paying braun and that's
why he'll be loyal to her at the
beginning of the season it'll just
create more drama later
if he doesn't die and he's still around
when they all make it back down there
the fact that he says his scenes weren't
that strenuous to film
does make it sound like he didn't have
any really huge long battle scenes
hopefully he doesn't die before he gets
to have some really cool badass battle
scenes but there will be fighting going
on down at king's landing eventually
regardless of which theory you want to
endorse
about the timeline of events then of
course number one we have to talk about
the new
upgraded season eight intro sequence so
i can't play the clip in here for
obvious reasons but you just see ice
tiles flipping over on the sort of map
table board
spreading outward from the wall south
encompassing the last hearth which
implies that because they built it out
we will go to the last hearth during the
episode makes sense because that's the
closest castle south of east watch by
the sea that's probably where the white
walkers would head first but you travel
in and around the north much much more
because remember we don't really need to
go to the east in the episode we're
mostly
in and around winterfell up in the north
and down and around king's landing so
they're just spending more time
on the map in a much bigger way around
those locations
there was also a separate brief clip
that made it online of the portion of
the intro with king's landing in the red
keep
one of the big upgrades during the
season 8 version of the intro sequence
is that the camera goes down
inside the red keep through the throne
room in down below
where blairie and the black dread skull
is in that storeroom that we saw during
season 7
directly below the iron throne so you
ask what is the point of going down
inside the red keep during the intro
sequence other than just to make it look
really cool and spend a bunch of extra
money making a new version of the intro
well what they can do now episode to
episode is show you physical changes
inside the throne room so if daenerys's
vision from the house of the undying
comes to pass
and the red keep is partially destroyed
and you see snow falling in
they can show you physical changes to
the inside of the iron throne room
episode to episode based on the intro
sequence in the way that they've changed
the different locations season to season
based on what's happening there like
when the boltons had winterfell during
season five you saw the flayed man sigil
instead of the stark sigil you saw smoke
billowing out and that lasted for quite
a while so they added this much detail
to the red keep i would also expect it
to be the same up at winterfell although
we haven't seen that part of the intro
sequence yet
so what will happen is i'll be doing a
couple other big bonus videos just to
get everybody ready for the start of the
season
then for the most part all the videos
that i do episode to episode will be
just like i've done in previous seasons
i'll add links to my playlists at the
end of this so you can watch some of
those to get a sense for what they're
like
but if you've been a subscriber for a
couple seasons now then you know the
drill you know all the videos that i'm
gonna make for it if you're brand new to
the channel don't worry i'll try to
remind people about the video schedule
episode to episode as we go along
congratulations dimitri nesbit you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
game of thrones video please email me on
the about page of my channel so i can
get your details
click here to watch that last big teaser
trailer and click here for those other
brand new promos that they dropped
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome we are almost there the
season has almost
started
you